die zeit
mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché et comme j'ai la flemme de
trouver une raison
eh ben on se débrouillera sans voilà
c'est tout
bonjour à toutes et à tous trouvant une
raison pour laquelle le doit faire
pénitence ben je sais pas j'ai traité
les gens de connard dans ma dernière
vidéo donc voilà une bonne raison
bonjour bonjour bonjour et bien ça va
être reparti pour une séquence de
pénitence pénitence qui va être d'autant
plus douloureuse que c'est la onzième
déjà 11e pénitence et j'étais persuadé
qu'un chemin de croix avait douze
stations
donc je pensais que j'arrivais à la fin
et en fait non non il ya quatorze
stations dans un chemin de croix donc il
faut encore que je fasse pénitence pour
trois épisodes après celui la finesse
pourquoi j'ai choisi le pourquoi j'ai
choisi le chemin de croix bref voilà
pour ceux qui savaient pas voilà la
référence religieuse des bonnes kg
pénitence c'est le chemin de croix donc
je suis en ce sens et faire quatorze
stations 14 vidéos où je souffre et qu'y
at il de plus douloureux que de regarder
ses propres vidéos les vieilles vidéos
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on va
s'attaquer à notre vieille vidéo islam
et darwinisme l'origine de la théorie de
l'évolution
sorti en 1990 si vieux que ça quand même
sorti en 2014
le 13 mars 2014 publié par une petite
gêne que peut-être vous connaissez pas
qu'ils s'appellent entracte science
vidéo qui a fait 38 mille vue donc ça
fait plus quand même que nos vidéos
moyenne donc ça compte pour un déblocage
et pénitence et c'est un truc que j'ai
vraiment vraiment vraiment pas envie de
faire parce que comme j'ai dit c'est une
vieille vidéo et que généralement
regarder ces vieilles vidéos ça fait un
peu mal au cul l'info bien faut bien
l'admettre c'est une vieille vidéo et
j'ai choisi celle là non pas seulement
parce que associer le mot islam
darwinisme tebben cache dans le même
titre
ça va faire des millions de vues mais
surtout parce que dans cette vidéo là on
on dit quand même pas mal de on arrondit
pas mal d'anglais c'est une façon de
dire qu'on dit beaucoup de conneries
sans avouer qu'on dit beaucoup de
conneries on arrondit beaucoup beaucoup
d'angles et je sens que ça va faire mal
à regarder et j'ai pas envie de le faire
mais ça fait très longtemps que je dois
le faire ça fait très longtemps qu'il
faut que je reprenne que je fasse un
débriefing de cette vidéo et le fait est
que plus j'attends pour faire un
débriefing et plus ce débriefing va
ressembler à un déblocage donc c'est
pour ça que je trouve que ça va être
parfait pour un débrayage et pénitence
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va être
dur il va être très dur alors allez
c'est parti
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette fois en
question stop science for question pour
laquelle je reçois abdessamed donc
abdessamed bonjour les tap tap les abdou
peut-être ce sera plus simple
abdou donc tu est diplômé de géologie de
l'université d'oran en algérie ainsi que
de paléontologie à l'université de
montpellier en france et donc ensemble
et bien nous allons parler de l'origine
de la théorie de l'évolution car
peut-être ne le saviez vous pas mais les
premiers à avoir parlé de d'évolution
des espèces dans l'histoire des sciences
et bien ce ne sont pas parce ce ne sont
pas des savants occidentaux et surtout
pas darwin away bas des jambes on peut
commencer
commençons par le début le pauvre abdou
que j'ai traîné dans cette vidéo dont il
est il était content de le faire mais si
vous voulez il connaissait pas plus que
ça il déjà déjà moi je connaissais pas
grand chose sur le thème des savants
musulmans médiévaux qui ont parlé de
l'évolution des espèces avant darwin
déjà moi je connaissais pas grand chose
à l'époque mais alors plus lui lui lui
gelé vraiment traîné sur cette vidéo
tout simplement parce que je voulais son
expérience personnelle sur le sujet
évidemment vu qu'il a été vu qu'il a
suivi une éducation au maghreb
je voulais son avis sur la question
parce qu'il a évidemment il a pu voir de
ses propres yeux ce qui est l éducation
au darwinisme en afrique du nord donc
bon bref donc le pr abdou jeu les
traîner là
mais bon on a été très content de faire
ça ensemble et puis on était on était
très amis on est toujours très habile
d'ailleurs même si on joue on a pu
tellement l'occasion de se voir mais on
est toujours très amis et donc où elle
donc à l'époque on n'avait pas beaucoup
de sources je vais vous montrer la quasi
enfin on en a quand même citer
quelques-unes en dessous de la vidéo il
ya quand même un paquet de sources qu'on
a cité mais notre principale source pour
cette vidéo c'était cet article donc un
article de mohammad sultan cha paru en
paru en 2010 je crois je ne suis pas sûr
et qui donc fait le résumé des des
savants près darwinien qui ont parlé de
l'évolution donc c'est un article qui
est quand même assez bien fourni je
dirais qu'il fait une liste de tous les
savants musulmans qui ont pu parler de
près ou de loin d'évolution le bas le
truc c'est que c est qu une seule source
il faut bien dire les choses faut bien
dire les choses ça n'est qu'une seule
source et en fait je crois que c'est
juste un résumé de congrès en fait c'est
même pas un article il est résumé de
congrès ils sont pas toujours peer
review vais donc bon donc c'était un peu
maigrichon voilà comme départ on va dire
on était vraiment sûr du départ
maigrichon alors de pluie il ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont sortis mais déjà elle
est pas qu il ya des choses qui étaient
sortis mais depuis il ya d'autres choses
qui sont sentis notamment cet article là
donc là l'histoire non dit de en
biologie celle de la continuité des
idées révolutionnaires chez les savants
musulmans du viiie siècle jusqu'à darwin
donc je suis là c'est un vrai article
péril uv qui est sorti dans la revue
journal of biological éducation qui est
sorti en 2018 donc il est relativement à
jour et suis là voilà c'est du vrai
c'est du bonbon vallée sorti chez c'est
un journal qui appartient à telle heure
et francis donc cette grande chaîne
d'édition scientifique vous avez rouid
audio go parmi les auteurs qui est aussi
un grand
je crois que c'est un paléontologue en
tout cas c'est ça fait partie des gens
qui travaillent en biologie évolutive de
façon régulière depuis déjà bien des
années
c'est un nom qui revient très souvent
bref il y a
y'a plus il ya quand même un plus grand
engagement de qualité dans cet article
la queue dans l'article de sultane chat
qui même s'il est très fourni et les
deux articles d'ailleurs raconte à peu
près les mêmes choses quand même
j'aurais plus tendance à faire confiance
à celui ci voilà d'autant que l'article
l'article de sultane chat diffère de
celui de malik je crois que le premier
auteur c'est malik voilà amina malik
diffèrent surtout par la faim la
conclusion la conclusion c'est que de
l'article de sultane chasser que darwin
avait très bien pu lire d'ailleurs lui
dit actually study ii about évolution
chemise blanche fender nm10 band father
was actually connecter tous donc voilà
darwin a pris de l'évolution de son
grand père et son grand père
après un bep lui même a pris apparemment
de savants musulmans enfin en visant les
revenus musulmane et là ils
connaissaient donc les les écrits arabes
et musulmans voilà donc darwin aurait
été capable de lire l'arabe et aurait
donc lui les savants musulmans bon cccc
conjecturale au mieux comme on dit dans
la vidéo
faux ça n'a jamais été dit dans aucune
des biographies de darwin qui savait
lire l'arabe et qu'il avait eu ses idées
à part à propos de la théorie de
l'évolution depuis depuis des écrits des
savoirs donc un arabo musulman voilà
donc donc donc voilà cet article là il
est quand même un peu plus un peu plus
fourni un peu mieux un peu mieux source
et et il ya aussi d'autres écrits qui
ont qui ont été publiées alors notamment
celui là la couverture je suis désolé
pour la couverture c'est pas moi qui
décide de qui veut de ce chrono mais sur
les couvertures des livres mais
islamique théorie aux évolutions de
missing link between darwin andy origin
of species par chavanat qui est sorti en
2010 ce qui est apparemment un bouquin
de référence quand il s'agit de lier
théorie de l'évolution et savants
musulmans médiévaux mais le problème
c'est que la couverture elle envoie pas
du rêve la couverture sans dire un gag
sérieusement en tout cas voilà
apparemment ça c'est une référence quand
il s'agit de discuter théorie de
l'évolution et savants musulmans du de
l'époque médiévale
et évidemment il ya les écrits de nidhal
guessoum un astrophysicien mais qui est
versé dans toutes les sciences équipes
discutent beaucoup justement de
l'histoire des sciences dans le monde
arabo musulman donc nidhal guessoum
aussi une grande référence pour cette
question là bref continuons donc on
était partis où on partait ou l'on
partait un peu léger en valais on était
montés léger au démarrage mais mais on
ya mis de la bonne volonté mais en
réalité bien ce sont des savants arabes
issus du monde musulman médiévale donc à
une époque où on déjà vrai c'est une
erreur que je viens de refaire un
instant par les deux savants arabes non
on parle de servants musulmans savent en
arabe c'est ce qu'ils viennent de la
péninsule arabique
les savants musulmans c'est ceux qui
viennent du monde musulman en général
quoi donc le monde musulman médiévale
qui recouvrait à peu près tout depuis
d'espagne jusqu'à l'inde et enfin
jusqu'aux indes et même encore plus loin
jusqu aux philippines donc il ya c'est
quand même un peu plus que seulement la
péninsule arabique ceci dit les savants
dont on va parler là viennent
essentiellement du maghreb et du monde
persie donc c'est vraiment le le monde
arabo-musulman à dire quand quand on
pense quand on pense islam c'est quand
même la région qui s'étend sur le
maghreb lé l'arabie et puis le
moyen-orient qu'on visualise quoi c'est
pas c'est pas les philippines non plus
ou l'espagne ceci dit il ya un savant
espagnol dans le tas even even to file
donc ils veulent tous file qui
apparemment est né en espagne en 1110 en
1117 ont qu'à l'époque où l'espagne
était encore valable andalousie
notamment étaient encore musulmane
donc il ya quand même eu des savants qui
venaient d'horizons beaucoup plus varié
que juste le maghreb le moyen-orient et
la rade ou en europe
on se vautre est un peu dans le
moyen-age à sanaa je ne vais pas
m'arrêter tous les deux phrases comme ça
mais dire qu'on se vautrait dans le
moyen-âge il ya tout le monde qui m'est
tombé dessus sur ça mais bon faut bien
admettre que le moyen âge c'était pas
non plus c'est pas non plus une autre
période de gloire niveau niveau
évolution des sciences on va être voilà
niveau l'évolution technologique non
plus il ya d il ya des avancées
technologiques qui ont été faites au
moyen-âge mais en forme quand même dire
que niveau progression scientifique
on retient surtout en occident du mois
on retient surtout la grèce antique et
la renaissance et ce qui est venue après
la renaissance notamment les temps
modernes le moyen-âge c'est quand même
pas on retient pas le moyen-âge surtout
pour ses avancées scientifiques donc il
faut comme un enfin le diront qu'on peut
glorifier moyen-âge pour beaucoup
d'autres choses et ça c'est vous qui
décidez mais niveau scientifique on peut
pas dire qu'en occident c'était quand
même le voilà c'est évidemment jeu en
plus c'est de l'enregistrement en direct
quoi donc j'essaye à peux me défendre
voilà je dis ce qui me vient à ce moment
là ouais les savants arabes peut parler
déjà astronomie il parlait chimie par
les cultures et il parlait évolution des
espèces aussi et beaucoup de
mathématiques aussi et beaucoup de
mathématiques exactement médecine
il surpasse et le monde occidental dans
bien des domaines
alors pour ceux qui n'ont pour ce sont
ceux qui n'ont pas compris cette vidéo
est ma vidéo probablement la plus islamo
gauchiste voilà donc on vient de faire
la vidéo féministe juste avant
maintenant on fait la vidéo islamo
gauchiste non mais évidemment ça m'a été
énormément reprocher de vouloir mettre
l'islam au centre de tout comme comme
beaucoup de gens qui sont l'islam au
centre et veulent le faire
non il s'agit juste il s'agit juste
évidemment de remettre les choses à leur
place c'est à dire qu'il ya des savants
qui ont parlé d'évolution des espèces
avant darwin et c'est normal de parler
d'eux et il se trouve que culturellement
ils étaient tous associés au monde
musulman qui aurait peut-être besoin
d'un peu
une petite remise à niveau faut savoir
que le moyen-âge donc ils commencent
officiellement en 476 à la chute de
l'empiré romain de l'empiré romain
d'occident et qu'à partir du début du
moyen-âge et dias c'est le monde arabe
le monde musulman qui va prendre le
relais des savants et des philosophes
grecs et qu'il va sauver ni terreau
allemand le savoir est décuplée ce
savoir ce qu'il faut peut-être préciser
ce que c'est que c'est que y'avait pas
que les arabes mais avaient aussi les
chinois la civilisation chinoise
si je pense qu'ils savaient beaucoup de
contributions là tu es donc je pense
qu'il y avait un certain partage entre
les arabes et aussi les chinois salon
qu' il y avait beaucoup beaucoup des
chemins entre ces deux civilisations
c'est vrai qu'ils étaient à l'interface
donc les hélas pour le moment fait on
quand on n'est vraiment pas beaucoup
beaucoup de choses pour ce qu'il s'agit
de leur civilisation arabe et non plus
l'interaction entre cette civilisation
et la civilisation chinoise donc
j'aimerais bien juste faire un petit
accent là dessus justement être lui dit
tu dis qu'on sait assez peu de choses
sur ce monde arabe mais finalement au
niveau de l'élite toujours l'amalgamé
entre le monde arabo musulman et ce
qu'il faut mais il ya des questions qui
m'ont été posées là dessus dans les
commentaires tellement pourquoi pourquoi
la chute de cet empire musulman déjà
enfin lempire musulman n'est pas n'est
pas restée une entité pendant très
longtemps a duré un siècle je crois et
après ça s'est fragmentée et puis ça
s'est réuni et le fragmenter et la
dernière réunion en fait d'un empire
musulman centré autour de la
méditerranée ça a été la pire ottoman
qui lui même si l'erreur fragmenté en
1918 quand l'empiré ottoman a perdu la
première guerre mondiale et que le fait
qu'il est devenu la turquie donc c'est
une très longue histoire de la
fragmentation de 7
cette unité entre guillemets musulmane
si elle a jamais existé cette unité
musulmane
c'est une très longue histoire mais en
gros c'est pour rebondir sur ce que dit
abdou tout tient à la route de la soie
c'est à dire que tant que la route de la
soie a fonctionné à fonctionner plein
pot la chine et le monde musulman qui se
situer sur la route de la soie était
super riches
par contre à partir du moment où les
occidentaux ont trouvé un moyen de
bypass et la route de la soie en ouvrant
de nouvelles voies commerciales
notamment maritimes
donc à partir de 2015 2400 et quelques
quand notamment avec l'invention de la
caravelle la chine et le monde musulman
où commençait à décliner du point de vue
richesse moins de richesses égal moins
de moyens a dédié à la recherche aux
sciences et moins de moyens aux sciences
égale déclin scientifique
donc c'est c'est un peu ça c'est
globalement ça qui s'est passé c'est
juste l'ouverture des voies commerciales
des européens a coupé la route de la
soie donc l'afflux de richesses mais ça
s'est pas fait du jour au lendemain
comme je dis là je parle de 1600 la fin
de l'empiré ottoman c'est 1918 donc on
parle d'un très très très très très long
très très long d'éclat entre guillemets
une très très longue fragmentation
éducation est ce que c'est trés
enseigner parce que nous en france on
n'entend pas parler de ça littéralement
un jeu dire on a on a des cours sur sur
l'époque médiévale en france par année
au primaire quand on est au collège on
entend un tout petit peu parlé d'
averroès pour pour ce qui est de la la
renaissance du début de la renaissance
donc averroès qui était
un savant arabe mais des espagnols mais
plus savoir arabe espagnol comment
voulez vous ne pas vous énervez
conneries comme ça
[Rires]
mais l'espagnol d'ailleurs averroès
magnifique exemple sélectionné sur le
fil à puisque averroès est probablement
le seul qui a jamais parlé de révolution
des espèces je veux dire on en a une
liste suffisante pour faire des articles
complets voir des livres complets
évidemment on va choisir averroès qui
est le seul qui en a pas parlé
pour le reste vraiment on ne connaît pas
ces savants alors est ce que est ce que
c'est pareil aussi dans un monde
musulman e basse et c'est vraiment c'est
pareil donc c'est pareil je trouve que
c'est super bon abdou est algérien mais
enfin il peut pas parler pour le monde
musulman entière avec tout avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour lui me posez la
question c'est ma faute en fait c est ce
que c'est pareil dans le monde musulman
lui demande at il alors qu'il l'est
algérien je veux dire il n'a pas voyagé
dans tout le monde musulman pour savoir
à ce que les autres font quoi donc c'est
la grosse question tient à un guet-apens
prend le dans ta gueule
désolé abdou désolé d'avoir fait ça que
c'est tellement très mal enseigné que
hong kong est vraiment pas même pas un
tiers de des savants musulmans et voire
même quand on entend plus parler de ces
savants dans les rues dans les mosquées
plus que colomb des écoles et
universités c'est vraiment dommage donc
cet aspect là de l'histoire donc
l'histoire des sciences
tu parles plus en plus précisément en
algérie parce que c'est mon pays je
prends mon petit peu le monopole là bas
c'est totalement ignorée mais c'est
vraiment il ya ces camps enseigner et je
me demande pourquoi c'est fait depuis
depuis mon enfance à moi donc j'ai reçu
que des des cours sur des complots
qualité sur sûr
anti ride en gare de l'indépendance et
et voilà il nous apprend vraiment
quelques flashs d'avant derby c'est
quelqu'un de grand savoir musulmans tels
que par exemple lors elle donne très peu
de goût china et beaucoup beaucoup de la
guerre d'indépendance loges pour
commencer j'aimerais commencer par une
citation de heaven meskaoui iben
meskaoui qui était donc un savant perse
qui vivait entre 930 et 1030
donc là on est quasiment 1000 ans avant
darwin et qui déjà à l'époque disait
l'animalité arrive finalement à la
frontière de l'humanité chez le singe
qui est juste un degrés au-dessous de
l'homme dans l'échelle de l'évolution
qui n'est pas une citation de heaven
miss kawaii à cette pochette
ce n'est pas une bonne miss kawaii qui a
écrit ça voilà j'ai honte j'ai honte
maintenant c'est pas c'est pas lui qui a
écrit cela alors du fait j'ai tiré sa de
sultane chat qui parle de heaven is
kawaii je vais vous retrouver ça tout de
suite alors s'il tonne chat qui les a
mis dans l'ordre chronologique mais avec
des années
je crois que les années occidentales
sont à droite voilà 32 je crois que ça
correspond avec l'année qu'il y voyez
ici 1032 ça correspond avec l'année que
j'ai mis sur la vidéo way plus ou moins
que sur les dates on n'est pas
complètement d'accord donc sultane chat
je crois que c'est de là que j'avais
tiré cette phrase c'était ou de là où
deux de faouzia charfi libre de faouzia
charfi que je cite à la fin de la vidéo
mais en tout cas qui bonne miss k way il
n'a pas dit ça en fait il n'a pas
exactement 10 à ce qu'il a dit
exactement et ses cités dans cet article
la voilà donc ce qu'il a dit exactement
c'est que le premier pas vers la censure
des plantes jusqu'à un ordre nous un
ordre plus haut qui délibère du sol et
de leur besoin de consolider leurs
veines d'ananas le premier stage de la
le premier étage des animaux est faible
les animaux de sept étages reste faible
en locomotion
bien que ils sont libérés du sol et il
évolue une nouvelle vie et après il
évolue depuis cet étage et acquiert la
capacité de mouvement et leur sens
deviennent plus forts c'est le cas des
verts et des papillons et des animaux
rampant la sensibilité de ces animaux
devient plus forte et de la émergent les
quatre sens comme chez la taupe et les
autres qui lui ressemble et de là les
animaux progressivement évolué vers un
nouveau degré dans le who il acquiert la
vue c'est le cas des fourmis et des
abeilles et il n'a proche du dernier
stage de la dernier étage des animaux
donc le dernier stage qui sera
évidemment les les mammifères et ce
dernier étage qui est supérieur
néanmoins reste inférieur à celui des
singes et celui des sages de
se rapprochent celui des humains en
structure est en apparence humaine
il n'y a pas de 10 francs de différence
entre les singes et nomme excepté un
petit tout petit qui qui s'est surpassé
quand ils deviennent humain donc
évidemment cette différence c'est
l'intelligence comme expliqué plus loin
dans le texte donc voilà ça c'est la
vraie citation d'euskadi bonne miss
kawaii alors la différence avec ce qu'on
vient de voir ici c'est que l'animalité
arrive finalement à la frontière de
l'humanité chez lesage qui est juste un
degré ou dessous de l'homme dans
l'échelle de l'évolution
bon la différence c'est que c'est déjà
beaucoup moins claires sur est ce que
l'homme descend du singe à ce qu'il nous
dise et que donc le niveau des sages est
au dessus du niveau des autres
mammifères en gros qu'il s'approche de
l'humain en structure est en apparence
et qu'il n'y a pas de différence entre
les humains et les singes
excepté l'intelligence vous voyez que le
mot évolué qui est présent au dessus
na la voilà n'apparaît pas quand il
s'agit du singe et de l'homme et jeu et
d'ailleurs ça ça aussi c'est une
citation d'un autre article n'est pas
directement de iben miss kawaii donc ça
c'est probablement une traduction
donc c'est pareil le mot évolué est ce
que est ce que c'est vraiment le mot
qu'a utilisé une bonne mise car oui on
assiste aussi là dessus dans la vidéo
allez les problèmes de traduction le la
langue
évidemment la langue arabe qui était pas
qui était écrite par les savants
musulmans à l'époque médiévale n'est pas
la langue arabe moderne
évidemment elle est très très dur à
traduire comme l'est d'ailleurs l'ancien
français par exemple
c'est assez différent du du français
qu'on parle aujourd'hui donc c'est assez
dur de traduire et mais on note quand
même que ses tresses et ça reste assez
essentialiste ça reste assez et celle
des êtres humains on a beaucoup dit
aussi que le concept d'évolution
existait déjà chez les grecs alors chez
les grecs ce qu'on a c'est
aristote qui avait une échelle des êtres
donc une gradation des êtres mais il n'y
avait pas de transformation entre les
entre eux on à platon qui lui par contre
c'était essentialisme à mort donc il est
n'est pas évolutionniste pour un sou et
après on a d'autres savants grecs qui
étaient entre guillemets transformiste
dans le sens où il acceptait qu'un être
humain pouvait se transformer en autre
chose mais enfin je verse et autant de
la théorie de l'évolution que le loup
garou quoi un loup garou qui sans ce
jeune homme qui se transforme en loup
c'est pas de la théorie de l'évolution
voilà c'est juste c'est juste de la pl
métamorphose quoi c'est pas vraiment de
la théorie de l'évolution
donc dire que les grecs avaient un
prototype de théorie de l'évolution loi
est le meilleur proto type de théorie de
l'évolution qu'ils avaient c'était
aristote et sa chaîne des êtres voilà la
fameuse ce cas la nature à l'est mais la
scala natura et c'était elle n'était pas
imperméable
voilà là il ya quand même une idée de
perméabilité entre les échelons qui
n'existe pas ou qui du moins n'est pas
aussi clairement exprimé que dans que
chez aristote quoi donc
donc il ya quand même il ya quand même
des choses il bonne miss kawaii il a
quand même dit des choses intéressantes
il faut il faut rendre à césar ce qui
est à césar
il ya cette idée quand même que l'homme
est le sage il ya un truc qui se passe
même si c'est pas clairement dit qu'ils
évoquent l'un évoluant l'autre et il ya
une idée de perméabilité dans l'alaska
la nature et donc c'est typiquement le
ce qu'on avait dit au début qui est les
non seulement les musulmans les savants
musulmans médiévaux se sont réappropriés
les écrits grecque mais ils ont ils ont
construit par dessus ils ont continué à
rajouter du savoir donc ça c'est déjà
plus proche de ce que les bonnes mais ce
cavayé a dû dire en partant du principe
que c'est une traduction fait part à huy
en 1974 et en dessous on a cette autre
phrase mais qui cette fois être
rapportée par shaw ja et alors là c'est
une communication personnelle je ne sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire pour être
honnête
quand on fait une citation comme salle
de type citation personnel ça veut juste
dire que quelqu'un d'autre vous l'a dit
donc ça un mec m'a dit que deux points
où vous allez y mais iban muscat hoyé
avait dit que le sage
enfin le grand sage là parce que c'est
le mot hype donc grand sage évoluent
dans leur en as un niveau inférieur
d'hommes barbare donc là on a l'idée
d'évolution depuis les grands sages
jusqu'aux humains
oui mais c'est à une communication
personnelle donc et en plus il est
précisé un peu plus haut que il que ces
grands singes sont pas forcément des
gorilles et des singes enfin des
gorilles et de chimpanzés des choses
comme ça mais qu'il est tout à fait
probable qu'en réalité ce soit des des
barbaries hape donc les singes de
barbarie ce qu'on appelle les singes
magot qui sont pas du tout des grands
sages en fait ce sont des petits
associant des cercopithèque aux ide donc
des proches parents des babouins mais
qui n'ont pas de queue et c'est pour ça
qu'on les appelle des barbaries hype
c'est juste parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
queue comme des grands singes mais c'est
juste une convergence des politiques on
reconnaît un petit touche de racisme
bien de chez nous évidemment
enfin évidemment tout le monde est un
barbare sauf sauf moi théorème universel
du barbarisme tout le monde est à
barbares sauf moi mais voyez cc c'est
vraiment chaud jacky rapporte que even
meskaoui a dit que les grands singes
évolue dans un niveau inférieur
donc à chaque fois en fait qu'on parle
du band meskaoui bizarrement c'est
rarement directement ce qu'a dit bonne
mais ce cas oui c'est toujours ce que
quelqu'un d'autre a dit de que lee byrne
meskaoui a dit voilà donc faut faire
très attention avec ça et on n'a pas
fait attention avec ça on s'est
complètement fait avoir avec ça même je
dirais c'est complètement fallu donc non
even meskaoui n'a jamais dit l'animalité
arrive finalement à la frontière de
l'humanité chez le singe qui est juste
un degrés au-dessous de l'homme dans
l'échelle de l'évolution perdu là
on retrouve deux notions enfin oui je le
rappelle on est entre 930 et 1030 et on
retrouve deux notions qui sont l'homme
descend du singe et on retrouve même le
mot évolution lui-même échelle de
l'évolution ou à l'exacte en face à nice
que oui justement qui est un père
personnes musulmans c'était l'un des
premiers qui a décrit ce processus
évolutive et qu' il y avait une certaine
limite floue entre montre entre le singe
et demain donc ça c'est un fait et avant
lui il y avait aussi quelques doté avec
quelques savants et voir beaucoup de
savants musulmans des fouilles et aux
offres notamment qui essayait de faire
un petit peu le lien entre l'animalité
et l'humanité d'accord mais on sent un
petit dérivé un peu de la scala natura
et d'aristote enfin les jeunes aux
risques qu'on appelle l'échelle de la
nature oui mon gradation depuis le
minéral jusqu'au jusqu'à l'animal
exactement ça a été repris par plusieurs
encore plusieurs savants musulmans
cancan exemple une musique la vie il y
avait une au sénat aussi qui a parlé de
qui a parlé de cette dégradation de la
création de thé puis deux puis des
organismes très archaïque jusqu'à
l'arrivée à l'homme le plus intelligent
bien sûr là il parle de gradation de la
création c'est important c'est important
parce qu'il faut bien faut bien préciser
qu' aucun de ces savants musulmans
n'exclut dieu du processus évolutif là
le but de la vidéo en général le but de
cette vidéo quand on l'a fait c'était
vraiment de dire que voilà islam et
l'évolution sont si c'est pas deux
entités complètement complètement
opposées l'une à l'autre
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on considère que
le
l'enseignement de l'islam est totalement
opposé à l'enseignement de l'évolution
cette vidéo c'était pour montrer que ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas que à
l'époque est révolue sioniste on va
parler théorie de l'évolution des
espèces et être musulman s'était pas du
tout opposés l'un à l'autre à l'époque
médiévale donc mais il faut quand même
rappeler qu' aucun de ces savants
musulmans médiévaux n'exclut dieu du
processus d'évolution
on en parle un petit peu après dans
cette vidéo justement que le coran dit
que dieu enfin à la craie et recrée et
généralement c'est ce que ces savants
musulmans entendre par évolution c'est à
dire c'est des recréations badr al din
tunisien qui a vécu entre 1338 1404 qui
disait donc regardons le monde de la
création il commence avec les minéraux
puis voilà regardons le monde de la
création
il donnera le dos voilà exactement
l'exemple je réponds plus j'aurais pu
mieux faire mon timing progresse de
façon fluide et graduelle vers les
plantes et les animaux
le dernier niveau des minéraux est
connecté au premier niveau des plantes
comme les mousses et les plantes sans
grain le dernier niveau des plantes
comme la palme et la vigne est connecté
au premier niveau des animaux comme les
escargots et les méduses qui n'ont que
le sens du toucher que le mot connexion
eu égard à ces groupes signifie que le
dernier niveau de chaque groupe est prêt
à devenir le premier niveau du groupe
suivant le plus haut niveau de
l'humanité fut atteint à partir de celui
des singes chez lesquels on retrouve à
la fois la sagacité et la tension qui
n'ont pas encore atteint le stade de la
réflexion et de la pensée donc là ça
c'est une vraie citation du général de
la sas et et puis pour le coup là ça
vient du mou kadima et le mou kadima
il est trouvable sur internet et le rang
traduit évidemment versions traduites du
kadima et le mot kadima il est trouvable
sur internet et c'est effectivement ce
qu'il ya d'écrit dedans et c'est
confirmé dans cet article ici voilà
c'est exactement là la phrase qui est
affichée là le plus haut niveau de
l'humain est atteint depuis celui des
sages donc là pour le coup il ya pas
confusion entre barbarie hape et monkeys
dans lequel la sagacité la perception
sont trouvés et qui n'est pas atteint
par là la vraie pensée et la réflexion à
ce niveau arrive le premier stade de
l'humain depuis le monde des singes et
c'est le c'est aussi loin que mes
observations vont donc c'est ivan rats
et là c'est vraiment immeuble brian kidd
la vie en 1370 donc là pour le coup
cette citation elle est vraie c'est pas
comme la précédente de heaven miska waic
était complètement fausse une fois de
plus donc lhi benkhaldoun formule 7
cette idée très précise de l'évolution
et de gradation depuis depuis minérale
jusqu'au mont de animal en passant par
le monde végétal est ce que cette pensée
était présentiel hélas hélas il donnera
deux pour le coup on peut le créditer
pour être la première personne qui a
clairement dit l'homme descend du singe
dans le cloud il n'y a pas trop de
doutes sur l'écrit que il pensait que
l'homme descendait du sage alors qu'avec
qu'ibn miss kawaii ça restait flou quand
ça resté assez flou dans le monde arabe
jusque quand on peut la faire remonter
jusqu'à guérison
7ème 8ème siècle oui pareil il pensait
un petit un petit peu quand verizon
sauf que bordeaux à cette époque ils
étaient avancées notamment avec la
mention de de la connexion donc là on
sent que même si c'est pas de
l'évolution de l'enfant sont strictes
dans son sens strict mais il y avait
quand même une pensée qu'il y avait une
évolution d'une forme à à une formule d
donc ça c'est très très important a
précisé
mais ce qui est important à préciser
c'est que al zaïdi déjà il a jamais
parlé de réellement d'évolution des
animaux dans quel giles adopte la scala
natura et une certaine continuité dans
la scala nature aille dans le sens où il
peut y avoir des transitions entre les
mais je ne sais pas clair c'est plus des
ca c est terré en fait un come porosité
entre les s'est pas complètement
essentialiste mais c'est pas non plus
évident qu'ils pensaient qu'il y avait
une réelle perméabilité entre les
échelles de la scala natura et à janis
il est surtout enfin je crois qu'on dit
al jadid pour le coup je ne suis pas sûr
al jadid il est surtout crédité pour
avoir été le premier à parler d'un truc
qui ressemble à la sélection naturelle
le truc c'est que j'ai téléchargé le
kitab al hayya one qui est trouvable sur
internet et j'ai regardé des articles
qui parlent qui parle du de l'oeuvre de
al zaïdi et notamment de son rapport à
la théorie de l'évolution et il est en
tout cas dans dans la traduction directe
du bouquin j'ai rien vu qui évoque ni de
près ni de loin la sélection naturelle
je pense que c'est un gros c'est un gros
raccourci que certaines personnes ont
pris de dire que al jahiz à parler de
sélection naturelle je veux dire il
parle évidemment de la concurrence entre
les animaux mais enfin de là à dire
qu'il parle de sélection naturelle c'est
quand même un peu c'est quand même un
peu fort de café
et puis là dans cet article là que je
suis en train de faire défiler je vous
le mettrez en descriptions dans cet
article la voilà
là il des banques le mythe du fait qu al
jahiz était un précurseur du darwinisme
ce que ce que dials giles ça c'est
vraiment pas aussi clairement
évolutionniste que qu'on le croit et l'a
donc cette phrase que j'ai surligner ici
qui résume très bien ce que j'essaie de
dire là la vision d'al qaïda n'est pas
fixiste mais le créationnisme est bien
présent voilà c'est clair et le est là
pour le coup ils vont ils vont aussi
loin que dire que le concept de
transformisme et de sélection naturelle
sont exclues de son raisonnement
donc oui il ya une idée de concurrence
entre les espèces qui est déjà
révolutionnaire je veux dire à janis on
est en 700 à 800 après jésus-christ quoi
donc on est on est déjà quand même si je
veux dire voilà l'idée de concurrence
entre les espèces mais aussi l'idée de
concurrence intra spécifique est
présente dans alza is et ç'a déjà niveau
écologie c'est balèze c'est balèze donc
il faut quand même rendre à alger de ski
et al jadid il a quand même
il avait quand même une vision de
l'écologie vachement avancé pour
l'époque
ceci étant dit pas de pas d'évolution
des espèces certainement pas d'homme
descend du singe
ça c'est complètement absent de l'oeuvre
de l'algérie en tout cas pour ce que
j'ai pu en voir et et puis sélection
naturelle font vraiment faire des gros
faut vraiment sûr interpréter le texte
pour pour trouver une idée de son
naturel de khalid chahid donc ce qu'on
est en train de raconter là c'est de la
grosse connerie en termes scientifiques
on appelle ça une grosse connerie mal au
cul après c'est bias via d'apprendre des
choses qu'on sait pas ce serait bien
aussi comprenant j'ai l'habitude si tu
veux j'ai pas l'habitude de critiquer
des comment dire des efforts honnêtes de
vulgarisation j'aime pas ça j'ai déjà
dit avant je n'aime pas critiquer les
efforts honnêtes de bulgares isation
j'aime bien critiquer les efforts très
très
malhonnête et très hypocrite de
vulgarisation voilà j'aime bien
critiquer ce genre d'effort de
vulgarisation à ceux qui ceux qui
prennent la vulgarisation par le mauvais
bout qui commence par la conclusion un
dieu existe et qui termine parle et qui
termine par les fait savoir qu est-ce
qui colle vous fait que dieu existe
voilà ça ça c'est le genre d'effort de
vulgarisation de jeunes critiques et là
il se trouve qu'on a on a quand même
essayé d'avoir une approche honnête de
ce sujet là mais c'est clair que à force
de vouloir déterrer des savants
musulmans qui ont parlé d' évolution
on a quand même finir par se perdre un
peu on va dire dans il faut absolument
qu'on parle de celui-là faut absolument
qu'on parle de cela faut absolument
qu'on parle de celui-là mais ont fini
par leur faire dire des trucs qui n'ont
pas dit voilà et ngize je pense que
c'est le pire
il y avait une belle miss kawaii où des
gens la citation coordonnées n'était pas
une vraie citation mais alors el jalil a
jamais dit ça tu avais aussi très
important la référence de la gélise où
il parlait un petit peu de quelques
mécanismes évolué tube alors juste pour
remettre en contexte algérie il a vécu
entre 776 et 868 donc là on est vraiment
sur le début du moyen-âge alors que
jelen kaboul lui il était vraiment sur
la fin du moyen-âge et alors début du
moyen-âge en 700t un peu 300 ans à la
bourre pour parler de début du moyen-âge
en tout cas si on prend là le
référentiel occidental est pourtant déjà
lui-même à janis avait déjà des idées
assez à ces nouvelles concernant
l'évolution à défaut d'être vraiment
évolutionniste il était pas fixiste en
fait du pensez vraiment que l'homme
avait évolué à partir de formes animales
de forme des descentes d'êtres humains
des humains sauvage on va dire là où il
a formulé une idée qui est qui et
inserts oui alors là on rejoint l'idée
de est ce qu'on parle d'évolution ou est
ce qu'on parle de transmutation de
métamorphose al zaïdi l'éclairement plus
proche d'eux dans sa philosophie il est
clairement plus proche de la
transmutation et de la métamorphose que
de l'évolution
donc on est plus proche des cinq ans
grec pour le coup si on dit que les
savants grecs n'étaient pas les premiers
à parler d'évolution peut pas vraiment
dire que l djaïz et parler d'évolution
intéressantes c'est qu'il parle d'une
sorte de combat pour la survie qui
serait qui serait une loi dictée par
dieu voilà combat pour la survie qui
quand même rappelle pas mal le struggle
for life
la sélection naturelle selon darwin
voilà exactement
enfin ça c'était peut-être pour dire que
algérie c'était le premier à 10 ans
évolutionniste un peu plus large arabes
musulmans effectivement il a abordé
oui évolutionniste dans un sens large ça
se met à la place pour le coup on est on
est vraiment en train de raconter que si
on prend l'évolutionnisme dans un sens
large ça veut dire qu'en gros avoir une
vague idée de sélection naturelle
c'est déjà de l'évolutionnisme c'est un
peu fort c'est faut vraiment faut
vraiment rendre le concept d'
évolutionnisme extrêmement floue et pour
eux dont les mécanismes concernant
l'évolution et il considérait que
c'était c'était le dieu c'était on va
qui était derrière les mutations les
mutations les transformations des
espaces et aussi vous mettre en évidence
que pareil là le concept de mutation on
n'aurait pas dû dire ça non plus on
n'aurait pas dû dire ça non plus le
concept de mutation évidemment qu'il
n'existe pas en 700 éventuellement de
transmutation j'imagine que ce que abdou
a voulu dire là c'est transmutation
comme je le disais la transmutation des
verts et la métamorphose mais pas
l'évolution
comment c'était
et qui a signalé qu'il y avait une
certaine le premier arabe qui a mis en
évidence une certaine transformation d
éjà interrompt encore abdul pour dire
que adjahi ce n'était pas arabe mais
irakiens donc peut-être certainement
ters en tout cas il venait pas de la
péninsule arabique c'est certain des
organismes donc algérie effectivement
c'était une première qui abordait de la
discussion sur le combat l'existence sur
la date
l'adaptation est aussi la psychologie de
l'adaptation ça c'est quelque chose qui
la bordent effectivement ça c'est vrai
ça c'est vrai mais encore une fois le
concept d'adaptation il n'est pas aussi
clairement défini qui dès aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quand on parle d'adaptation
on parle clairement d'évolution qui
conduisent à une adaptation ce que
aljibe décrit comme étant de
l'adaptation en fait si ce qu'on
appellerait plus tôt aujourd'hui de
l'accommodation c'est à dire des espèces
face et même pas les espèces et les
individus qui s'accommode de leur milieu
par des transformations éventuellement
morphologiques et physiologiques
par exemple le premier exemple qui me
vient mais qui n'est certainement pas
abordé par hadja is mais c'est l'exemple
des coraux les corps aussi le s'il ya
beaucoup de courant les coraux pour
devenir petit il est tour à tour à
boudry est très robuste et s'il ya très
peu de courant alors ils se mettent à
devenir arborescent est très grand et
très très ramifié très fin donc c'est
plutôt de l'éco morphologie là pour le
coup c'est sait comment les animaux où
diable tout simplement comment les
renards deviennent blancs ni vers les
renards des neiges sont blancs en hiver
et pas en été où les lapins par exemple
deviennent blancs en hiver comment les
animaux mu de manière générale en été et
réac hier leur leur pelage ou leur
plumage plus épais en hiver bref faut
pas confondre voilà ce que ce dont
parlait à janis quand il parlait
d'adaptation ça ça c'était un grand
mélange de ce que nous on appelle
réellement de l'adaptation aujourd'hui
c'est à dire vraiment de l'évolution et
de l'accommodation en fait qui est plus
qui est plus spécifique aux individus
l'accommodation n'est pas un phénomène
évolutif dans le sens où c'est les
individus qui s'adapte et que ces
adaptations ne sont pas transmissibles
en tout cas très peu transmissibles
évidemment on pourra toujours on va dire
l'épigénétique mais globalement c'est
accommodation sont pas transmissible de
l'animal
tu peux rappeler le titre du livre oui
bah le titre c'est le kitab notre
addiction
le livre de l'animal d'accord vous
mettrez un lien dans la description pour
que vous puissiez aller le voir vous
même bouclier en version originale ainsi
quand une version traduite qu'il n'a pas
d'ailleurs satisfait tant que ça mais
bon vaut mieux avoir
oui là ce que j'essaye de dire c'est que
j'ai pas trouvé du tout c'est que je
l'avais lu et que j ai pas trouvé du
tout deux mentions de près ou de loin
d'un truc qui ressemblerait à la
sélection naturelle
[Rires]
là je suis en train de vous arnaquer en
fait quand je dis sachez que je suis un
gros fumiste voilà je suis en train de
vous raconter que ça ne m'a pas
satisfait dans le sens où j ai pas
trouvé ce que j'espérais y trouver et
que tout le monde al'air d'ivoire alors
à ce moment là en fait quand je suis en
train de dire ça moi je me sens idiot
parce que je me dis mais tout le monde a
l'air d'y voir un grand d une grande
description de la sélection naturelle et
moi j'y vois que dalle voilà je j ai
rien vu tout ça donc ça m'a beaucoup
rassurée de voir cet autre article
donc celui là celui qui des banquiers
justement le l jaws et l'évolution parce
que du coup je me suis dit ah bah non en
fait c'était pas que moi il est sorti en
2012 je n'ai pas vu à l'époque
voyez je les consulte et qu'en 2019 donc
bref c'est voilà donc à ce moment là en
fait je me sens très con pas satisfaits
d'avoir trouvé d'avoir très insatisfaits
de ne pas avoir trouvé ce que j'étais
venu y chercher bon bah c'est peut-être
tout simplement parce que ce que j'étais
venu y chercher n'y était pas n'existe
pas et c'est pour ça que c'est important
d'une de citer vos références 1
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu
de source et tout ce que vous dites
parce que comme ça les autres ils
peuvent aller voir derrière blue et dire
mais attendez ça parle pas du tout de ce
que tu vis le lien que nous a donné et
c'est pour ça aussi qui est important de
lire les sources et de vous renseigner
sur ces sources parce que voilà vous
finissez par dire des conneries une
cette traduction que la traduction du
tout il ya des problèmes de traduction
et c'est une langue et qui est très
riche qui est difficile à traduire c'est
très très difficile donc on voit
beaucoup dans les traductions coranique
il ya beaucoup de contradictions entre
les auteurs et parfois c'est c'est un
peu néfastes répartira enfin c'est
tellement mal traduit que déjà à
l'époque de al jahiz l'idée d'évolution
a émergé de cette scala natura et de
aristote même déjà avant les stats y
avait une certaine idée de l'échelle des
êtres qui apparaissait donc sur un
artefact qui s'appelle le legrand race
de warcq a donc le vase du groupe
donc on est on est en mésopotamie groupe
donc on est déjà dans le monde perse
d'ailleurs l'irak l'iran et c'est déjà
sur ce vase de rocca par une certaine
gradation du vivant donc avec le monde
végétal tout en bas le monde animal au
milieu et les humains en eau est
intéressant mais comment dire est ce que
est ce que ça ressemble
est ce que ça représente vraiment une
scada natura et où est ce que ça
représente seulement le les êtres
humains qui domine en fait le monde
agricole quoi donc le monde végétal
domestique est et le monde animal
domestique est lui aussi bien ou bien
est ce que c'est une vulgaire
coïncidence j'avoue ne pas m'être
renseigné assez sur le vase de warcq à
jeun vous ne toujours pas mettre
suffisamment renseigné sur ce vase le
fait est que je pense que là on est allé
trop loin en fait surtout moi là pour le
coup c'est moi qui suis allé trop loin
c'est vrai qu' on est certes dans le
monde perse mais on est bien avant le
monde musulman je viens trois meilleurs
avant jésus-christ on est très très
avant le monde
helmand par contre là où je maintiendrai
mes positions
c'est que à mon avis l'idée dé celle des
êtres c'est par aristote qui l'a inventé
c'est à dire que c'était quelque chose
qui flottait dans l'air l'idée d'une
certaine
comment dire l'idée d'une certaine
hiérarchie du vivant avec l'intelligence
au sommet et les cailloux en bas et
entre deux il ya des plantes qui bouge
pas et les animaux qui bouge et les
animaux intelligents que nous sommes ça
par contre je pense qu'il n'y a pas
besoin d'être aristote pour pour avoir
cette idée là et je pense que cette idée
l'échelle des êtres elle devait
probablement déjà être présente depuis
très très longtemps doit y avoir moyen
un jour de retrouver des peintures
rupestres qui représente une chance de
scan and natural j'aimerais que ça
existe mais je suis presque sûr que un
jour on retrouvera une peinture rupestre
qui nous présentera une ce cas la nature
et primitive
parce que parce que c'est je veux dire
c'est une idée qui vous vient assez
naturellement à l'esprit quand vous avez
cinq ans et demi quoi donc je vois pas
pourquoi ça n'aurait pas existé avant
bien avoir aristote aristote a
certainement eu le mérite d'être le
premier à l'écrire et d'être le premier
à coucher ça sur papier est le premier à
en discuter réellement de la perte de sa
pertinence
mais bon ou du moins à réfléchir à sa
pertinence même s'il ne discute pas
vraiment mais en tout cas voilà là là je
pense qu'on va un peu trop loin
clairement on va un peu trop loin
représentants de masse du rock comme une
preuve que la scala natura et a précédé
la ristote mais je pense toujours que
que la scala natura et a pressé d
aristote et et je suis presque sûr que
des gens dans les commentaires
maintenant tout de suite sont en train
de m'écrire d'état a des tas et des tas
d'exemples d'autres savants grecque et
même avant ça qu'ils ont déjà parlé d'un
truc qui devait ressembler la scala
natural et si vous en connaissez vous
gênez pas et de 7,2 cette échelle
naturel découle finalement l'idée
d'évolution de cette classification
rudimentaire découlent
d'une connexion depuis des êtres qu'on
pourrait appeler inférieur alors
inférieur avec beaucoup de guillemets
évidemment vers des êtres supérieurs et
donc ses idées elles sont elles sont
très bons termes pour pour un savant de
cette époque là et elle montre bien
finalement que l'idée d'évolution est
déjà dans l'air plus de mille ans avant
darwin et finalement ce que darwin a
apporté à ça c'est pas tellement
l'évolution lui attribue souvent à la
découverte de l'évolution
mais finalement c'est le ski l'année lui
c'est juste la sélection naturelle c'est
à dire pourquoi l'évolution et voilà là
c'est très important donc ce qu'on dit
c'est que l'évolution était déjà dans
l'air avant darwin et ça c'est clair
tout le monde le sait enfin je veux dire
personne ne contestera que erasmus
darwin donc son grand père parlait déjà
d'évolution des espèces
il ya eu robert chambers aussi qui
parlait d' évolution avant darwin il ya
eu évidemment la marque qui parle
d'évolution à bandar bin cuvier à bosse
a beau se être généralement représenté
comme un grand défenseur du
créationnisme et du catastrophisme il ya
des trucs dans les écrits de cuvier qui
laisse clairement à penser que le
transformisme quand même celle là un peu
touché quand il dit que chaque partie
des animaux se transforme en fonction de
la transformation des autres partis je
veux dire on n'emploie pas le mot
transformer en parlant d' animaux sans
être un minimum transformiste voilà donc
tu m'aimes cuvier qui n'était pas
transformiste qui se revendiquait comme
n'étant pas transformiste et qui était
farouchement opposé à la marque
il ya quand même un roulant de
transformistes donc c'est ça le c'est ça
que je veux dire c'est dans l'air mais
apparemment c'était dans l'air bien
avant ça ce qu'il faut préciser c'est
que tous ces savants musulmans dont on a
parlé et ce dont on n'a pas parlé parce
qu'il y avait une liste quand même quand
on regarde cet article là il y en a
plein d'autres dont on n'a pas parlé il
ya il ya donc al sahafa albert uni donc
to fail il en a parlé un peu à rudi tous
ces gens là ils ont quand même
il avait quand même l'idée d'une ce cas
la nature à il avait au moins
ça c'est à dire l'idée d'une scala
naturel qui était extrêmement poreuse
voilà il y avait une certaine idée d'une
scala natural et qui était plus ou moins
je vais pas dire extrêmement extrêmement
c'est pas le bon mais qui étaient plus
ou moins poreuse avec des passages d'un
étage à l'autre et avec notamment il
donnera lé 12 qui le plus clairement à
parler d'une porosité entre les singe et
l'homme porosité entre les singe et
l'homme qu'on retrouve légèrement
cheynis kawaii par exemple donc ça c'est
très intéressant et c'est intéressant de
constater du coup que de tous et
transformiste c'est très transformiste
j'ai envie de dire musulmans on voit
quand même une certaine gradation
jusqu'à ibn khaldoun le dernier d'entre
eux qui le plus clairement parle d'une
des de la descendance du singe à l'homme
donc ça c'est ça c'est très intéressant
est ce qu'il ya des encore plus
intéressant c'est que cette idée
justement de porosité de la scala natura
et on va la retrouver plus tard chez
d'autres chez d'autres penseurs
notamment chez lucilio vannini lucilio
vanine et qui a vécu qui a vécu qui a
vécu au xviie siècle donc né en italie
en 1585 est donc dans cet article de
qu'il fait la biographie de lucilio
vannini on nous explique que il a été
parmi ceux qui dès les premiers en
europe on parlait d'une des cendres de
l'homme qui descend du singe est ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant donc c'est qu'on
est en 1585 alors que libéral donne les
il a vécu entre 1300 et 1400 voyez il ya
une sorte de voix hier on voit ce
transfert en fait de la philosophie qui
a lieu depuis le monde arabo musulman tu
as du monde musulman
jusqu'au monde européen notamment par
l'espagne durant la renaissance et là
c'est pas une et c'est pas une je pense
que c'est pas une coïncidence si les
italiens italien c'est la renaissance et
la renaissance c'est pas un hasard si le
premier si le premier gars qui aurait
dit l'homme descend du singe en europe
était un italien et je pense que c'est
pas hasard qu'il qu'il ne vienne peu de
temps après il donnera 2 mais bon là on
est sur des preuves contextuel on peut
presque pas appeler ça des preuves
d'ailleurs pour dire les choses ainsi
c'est quasiment pas d'éprouver alors
après
ce qui est intéressant c'est dans ce
même article il ya une citation de
diderot qui nous vient du rêve
d'alembert donc c'est une citation qui a
été plein plein de fois re cité et
discuter d'un point de vue philosophique
d'un point de vue littéraire et c'est
donc ce n'est pas une citation cryptic
de diderot à ce que je veux dire
et donc ces citations c'est tout animal
est plus ou moins sommes tous minérale
et plus ou moins plante tout planter
plus ou moins un animal ne convenait pas
ne convenait vous pas que tout se tient
en nature et qu'il est impossible qu'il
y est un vide dans la nature donc on
retrouve encore une fois cette idée de
chaînes des êtres et de la porosité
encore une fois entre les entre les
étages de cet scan à natura est donc
déjà dans les philosophes des lumières
déjà chez les philosophes des lumières
vous avez aussi cette idée de porosité
dans la scala natura est donc cette idée
flottante
on va dire d'évolution qui est très
similaire à ce qu'on retrouve justement
chez ces savants musulmans et qui sera
on va dire le la base du transformisme
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
admet une porosité entre les échelles de
lascabanes nature à l idée de
transformisme et l'idée d'évolution
nisme derrière ça découle
assez naturellement est ce que darwin il
a ajouté comme on le dit dans cette
vidéo c'est juste le mécanisme c'est à
dire une fois qu'on a admis qu'il y
avait porosité une fois qu'on a admis
que la transe que ces transformations
d'espèces existait
comment on explique ces transformations
darwin dit c'est la sélection naturelle
c'est la sélection naturelle
c'est-à-dire juste voilà vous dans une
population donnée
si vous éliminez les plus petits et bâle
la génération prochaine de cette
population sera en moyenne plus grande
et si des petits sont encore éliminé et
la génération suivante sera en moyenne
plus grande et ainsi de suite jusqu'à ce
que l'espèce entière et grandit en fait
comme tout le monde attaque darwin
donc c'est l'évolution incarner mais bon
ma mère avant darwin
évidemment il y avait beaucoup de
savants dont il y avait beaucoup qui
faisait des réflexions vers ce sont
ceux-là donc darwin c'est pas tout mais
c'est juste un pièce d'anton un peu
effrayé là c'est très intéressant ce qui
vient de dire c'est que tout le monde
attaque darwin en s'imaginant qu'il
suffit d'attaquer la ruine pour démonter
la théorie de l'évolution ben justement
si darwin n'est pas le premier en avoir
parlé de la théorie de l'évolution ça
veut dire qu'il faut démonter tous les
gens avant lui y compris des savants
musulmans
l'énorme complexe on va dire darwin au
centriste est exactement mais même les
évolutionnistes à chaque fois ils sont
là darwin darwind ah oui exactement ça
juste pour que c'est quand même dommage
parce que on est en train de je ne sais
pas comment on les a mais on est en
train de négliger en quelque sorte avec
darwin tout ce qui a été fait et tout ce
que les champs essayer de faire
maintenant ne sais pas pourquoi les
jours auxi cote là dessus voilà down
dans l'essai comme c'est comme quand
même dieu alors que que si on lit bien
ce qu'il a écrit il ya beaucoup de
choses que je disais un monde qui peut
maintenant sont plus je ne sont plus
valables et non pas il ya plein d'autres
choses qui étaient déjà dit oui sans
cesse il a pu s'inspirer
ça c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de choses
que disait darwin qui sont plus valables
aujourd'hui notamment battu ce qui est
la transmission des caractères darwin
n'avait aucune idée de la génétique dont
qu'il connaissait pas grand chose en
transmission des caractères mais surtout
le registre fossile
quand on nous balance à la tronche ouais
mais n'y a pas de formes transitionnelle
dans le registre fossile c'est darwin
lui-même qui l'a dit bah ouais il a dit
ça en 1800 et des to share depuis on a
fait des progrès quand même bon faut
arrêter de délirer darwin ça c'est
clairement et je pense que cette vidéo
là on avait aussi fait cette vidéo là
dans ce but là c'est à dire que voilà
faut arrêter aussi de mettre darwin au
centre de tout ce qui est théorique
évolution darwini là il a posé une
pierre conséquente dans le mur de la
théorie de l'évolution mais ce n'est
qu'une pierre et qu'il faut pas oublier
toutes les pierres qui en chine
justement
c'est savoir oui c'est par exemple que
copernic c'est un pas des savants arabes
de musulmans bonhomme arabe pour sa
théorie de l'héliocentrisme on sait on
sait qu'en niveau des mathématiques le
monde a eu une influence formidable là
nous chiffrons nos chiffres sont des
chiffres arabes pour ne citer que son
run est méritée des chiffres indien de
ça 2 on va dire mais est ce que darwin
lui a eu connaissance des travaux de al
jahiz des travaux de ibn khaldoun des
réflexions de heaven meskaoui enfin la
réponse est non la réponse est non faut
arrêter de poser des questions ou la
réponse est ouvertement non par
évidemment comme je le disais notre
référence principale à ce moment là
c'était sultane chat qui soutenait que
oui mais bon la réponse est la réponse
est non par contre ça a eu une influence
dans le sens où comme je le disais juste
avant l'évolution était dans l'air le
transformisme était dans l'air et il
était déjà dans l'air depuis
suffisamment longtemps pour que dire que
les espèces évoluent se soit pas non
plus une grosse révolution quelqu'un qui
disait les espèces évoluent ouais la
belle affaire veut dire il ya une
porosité dans la scala natura est super
ce label à faire quoi donc il ya ça a
participé à l'acceptation de l'idée de
cette porosité de la scala nature et qui
est un terreau fertile pour l'émergence
d'une théorie de l'évolution
voilà et c'est d'ailleurs pas pour rien
que il ya plusieurs personnes qui sont
arrivés avec une théorie de l'évolution
en même temps darwin et wallace pour ne
citer qu'eux mais il ya eu aussi la
marque avant eux et voilà c'est pas pour
rien qu'il ya un moment où ce terreau
fertile à donner des émergences de
théorie de l'évolution d'un peu partout
quoi il y avait certains qui disent que
darryl a beaucoup appris de la
civilisation et apparemment il a été
fusillé man ils sont mal il a en scylla
il a été renseigné par le prof est servi
tout ce qui est relative à la
civilisation musulmane à la pensée arabe
à cambridge donc pas effectivement donc
apparemment ici inspiré donc mais ça
c'est je pense au fond c'est une info
une information à confirmer
quand tu peux nous dire quelle hauteur
sept personnes physiques en astronomie
ok donc en 300 le lien on le lien sera
dans la description de la vie noyau pour
accéder à cet article c'est vrai que
c'est au niveau des biographies
officielles de darwin c'est c'est pas
dire ça c'est pas du contenu n'est pas
connu donc effectivement mais peut-être
donc éventuellement il aurait eu accès à
cette à cette masse de connaissances
si je pense mais c'est surtout à prendre
avec des pincettes que c'est ignoble
un petit fond de vérité parce que les
seules références de cette époque
c'étaient les références c'était les
références musulmans et ceux qui les ont
vus que l'ancien civilisation a fait
l'ancienne civilisation
c'était c'était c'était les musulmans
que je pense que que ici vous pouvez
respirer
pour en revenir à ces sa mort à rabat
lors il y en a quand même il ya quand
même un paquet aurait une tripotée oui
la pac est justement tu tiens un article
de muramatsu le temps de chats dans les
mains tu peux nous dire à peu près
combien de hauts faits un descriptif des
savants qui en est fier il fait un
descriptive qui reste un très bref de
plusieurs musulmans du site il commence
par il commence par lg et puis il y
avait un frère habits qui a parlé qui
est très réputé cette personne philippe
el farabi qui a aussi abordé des sujets
relatives à l'évolution il ya avait
elle-même l'aude il y avait même
certaines certains y même c'était des
gens religieux qui croyaient à la
transformation de l'espèce et que
l'homme il n'est pas venu comme ça donc
mais c'était plus il est venu grâce à
des processus évolutive etc
il ya un hémicycle avis via un pylône in
donc elle véronique qui est un savon à
rabat un grand philosophe il y avait
aussi la ccabp l'oci là il faut
peut-être lui signaler c'est aussi le
père de la chirurgie et novare et ibn
sina c'est avicenne nous et on le
connaît sous le nom d'avicenne ceci
étant dit sultane chat le site quelque
part probablement ibn sina avicenne
je ne crois pas que dans ce que malik le
site non avicenne ne fait pas partie des
des savants musulmans que malick site
donc petit avec des petites conditions
concernant avicenne ibn tofail en fait
parce que j'ai l'impression en lisant
sur 1000 cet article que c'était c'était
l'une des personnes qui ont vraiment
poussé avec la réflexion très très loin
et vous non rechute et ne te fait te
file to fail c'est de justement c'est le
nez d'espagne si je me suis je ne
m'abuse alors ils veulent tous fait le
sait d'après l'article de malik
justement c'est un de ceux que je trouve
le mois remarquable en tout cas d'après
d'après cette source la cibn tout fait
il y là il a décrit apparemment dans une
de ses oeuvres il a parlé d'un d'un être
humain qui seraient nés de
une mare de bouillasse bouillonnante
en gros voilà il ya des bulles et des
bulles dans l'eau dans l'eau salée que
c'est les éléments de cette douce se
sont assemblés pour former un être
humain est certain il voit du coup une
sorte de proto théorie de la bio génèse
ici dans l'article de maliki les
rappeler quand même que dans les versets
coraniques et dans tous les sens dans la
bible et dans le dans la torah c'est
aussi de cette façon là que ce qui crée
un dense depuis la boue enfin depuis
l'argile en l'occurrence donc je pense
que ça fait beaucoup plus référence là
c'est mon avis personnel évidemment mais
je pense que ça fait quand même beaucoup
plus référence à la à la genèse que
réellement à la bio jeunesse pour le
coup
donc là c'est un peu je pense que ça
fait partie de ces éléments un petit peu
tiré par les cheveux quand on essaie de
trop justement cherché à regarder ces
savants musulmans il a dit si ce savant
musulman il a dit ça c'est la théorie de
l'évolution là je pense que ça fait
clairement partie des éléments qui sont
sûr interprété dans le sens
évolutionniste là pour le coup je la
référence enfin je veux dire un garçon
qui émerge de la boue ça fait quand même
beaucoup plus référence vous récit de la
genèse coraci de la biogée neige à dire
c'est pas c'est pas censé être un être
humain qui émerge de la boue et encore
moins un être humain de sexe masculin
dans la bio génèse s'il y avait vraiment
une référence à la bio génèse ça devrait
être des bactéries qui émerge de et
cette bactérie devrait se transformer en
autre chose et c'est autre chose en
autre chose
est ce une autre chose en primates et
enfin vous auriez un être humain compte
mais là et là éventuellement on pourrait
parler de d'aressy de la biogénétique
mais là pour le coup un être humain qui
émerge de la boue directement
ça fait pas trop référence je pense à la
théorie de l'évolution
c'est même complètement l'opposé en
réalité
qui aurait développé l'idée justement de
la sélection naturelle exactement
beaucoup plus loin que janis l'avait
fait exactement en fait c'est lui qui a
parlé de la compétition en condition
pour la nourriture au combat sur
l'existence qu'il ya peut-être un
développement et la transformation des
deux langues and animals justement pour
qu'ils puissent bien défendre et
protéger son environnement il ya un an
ne te fais juste pour préciser qu'ils
avaient qu il ait vécu en 1120 jusqu'à
mille 180 kw à 86 et puis très très très
donc oui effectivement event to fail a
développé une idée qui semble être assez
proche de l'adaptation à l'environnement
et du combat pour la vie donc de la
sélection intraspécifique et inter
spécifiques qui sont des concepts
évolutif qui ont ensuite été développé
par darwin dont malik est talent vont
dans ce sens là aussi ceci étant dit
encore une fois est-ce qu'on est
beaucoup plus élaboré que jack is de ce
point de vue là je suis pas sûr on peut
vérifier ce que ce qu'en dit justement
sultane chat donc si le touch à part
évidemment du passage avec l'habit
fermenté voilà donc qui est plus
créationnistes selon moi que qu'autre
chose et il aurait développé l'idée qu'
effectivement seul le plus le plus
adapté survie mais enfin ça encore une
fois est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut
réellement parler de concept évolutif
c'est plus un concept d'écologie on le
fit à oignies de phytos ovale c'est plus
un concept d'écologie c'est à dire que
si vous leur attacher pas à l'idée que
la population civile rattachée pas cette
idée de survie du plus apte à l'idée de
transmission des caractères voilà de
descendance avec modification vous avez
absolument pas un prototype de théorie
de l'évolution quoi la survie du plus
fort la loi de la jungle à elle toute
seule c'est pas un concept évolutif du
tout
aujourd'hui on a tendance à l'associer à
la théorie de l'évolution parce que
justement on sait que la théorie de
l'évolution existe mais faut vous
imaginer que dans un monde près darwinia
ou la théorie de l'évolution n'existe
pas juste dire le plus fort est celui
qui survit ça ça veut juste dire que
c'est le plus fort qui survit ça veut
pas dire forcément que ce plus fort va
transmettre ces caractères à ses
descendants et que c'est d antan et que
ses descendants vont développer le
caractère et de transmettre aussi à ses
descendants etc etc
l'idée de la survivance du plus fort
tout seul sans l'idée de descendance et
sans l'idée de décence avec
modifications notamment toute seule elle
veut pas dire grand chose est en tout
cas tout seul on peut pas parler de
proto darwin et qu'en lieu
et puis il ya aussi fait savoir fragile
la gradation de la création et ses 500
entre 500 et 560 en crise
il était beaucoup plus ancien que lg ghz
et il pensait que voilà il y avait une
gradation de la création de puits et le
schéma classique des animaux et des
plantes plutôt très archaïque jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à l'homme l'homme
intelligent donc et même aussi la
dernière phrase qui manquent dé moitié
humain alors arrondi samarcande dit je
crois que c est le même que ni damien
roux dit ici ni d'amis à rudi je pense
que c'est même subtilement donc à roddy
samarcande dit il a vécu au xième siècle
c'est écrit là light eleven century
donc c'est assez cohérent ici avec tout
ce même siècle du coup donc je pense que
c'est le même mais là pour le coup
de toute façon enfin on avait déjà on
est en train de dire une grosse connerie
parce que les dates ont dit ses cinq
sens donc c'est avant elle janis non ses
cinq sens avec le calendrier musulman
hadj aïssa en calendrier musulman dit
tout en haut il est à 160 voilà donc les
genres d une grosse connerie l'a pas
vécue à voir al jahiz il a vécu au xième
siècle donc il était plutôt plutôt
contemporain si on regarde du coup de
ibn toufail beaucoup et pas loin de tout
s'y est pas loin non plus de libanais
jusqu'à wailly donc donc non on est
encore en train de dire des crucifix les
bêtes et donc lui développe aussi cette
idée de porosité dans la chaîne des
êtres apparemment avec un intermédiaire
entre l'humain et le entre l'humain et
l'animal qu'ils appellent le mas n'a du
coup pas on n'est toujours pas sur une
théorie de l'évolution puisqu'on a
toujours pas de mécanisme autre que l'
influence divine pour justifier de cette
transformation on peut réellement parler
de théorie de l'évolution qu'une fois
qu'on a atteint le niveau où on
s'affranchit la théorie s'affranchit de
l'âne être surnaturel pour expliquer que
des événements arrivent c'est pas une
théorie quand on dit c'est dieu qui l'a
fait c'est pas une théorie c'est juste
voilà vous fait intervenir un élément
surnaturel pour expliquer un truc que
vous connaissez pas une vraie théorie
c'est quand on s'affranchit enfin de cet
élément surnaturel et qu'on est capable
d'expliquer que avec des choses
naturelles matériel est observable
donc c'est le fameux matérialisme que
les religieux déteste autant c'est que
finalement c'est l'arrivée de ce
matérialisme dans la théorie cela
gestion de ce matérialisme dans la
théorie qui dégage les mentions naturel
plutôt très inquiet jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'homme l'homme intelligent donc
et même aussi là la dernière phrase qui
me dé moitié humain d'accord
les animaux seraient considérés comme
des demi donc là en fait la même façon
que voilà donc avant d'atteindre l'homme
il y avait des 2000 donc comme il était
dès 2020 donc ça ouais dire des demies
humain donc des sages c'est un petit peu
abusé un pour le coup là il utilise le
mot nasnas je suis pas exactement sûr de
ce que ça veut dire mais enfin on
n'exclut pas quand même la possibilité
qu'on parle juste de transmutation
encore une fois donc de porosité de la
scala naturel sans vraiment parler
d'évolutions qui m'a beaucoup marqué
c'est à tout si alors nacira dina
toxiques iranien qui a vécu entre 1200
et 1274 alors lui ce qu'il nous dit je
cite les organismes qui peuvent acquérir
de les nouveaux dispositifs sont
davantage variable en conséquence ils
gagnent des avantages par rapport à
d'autres créatures les corps change en
raison des interactions interne et
externe ce qui est de ce qui est marrant
dans cette dans cette citation parce
qu'ils me ce qui m'interpelle c'est
vraiment là on touche du doigt quasiment
la notion de la génétique il parle de
variabilité il parle davantage donc il
développe encore cette idée de sélection
naturelle et il dit que les corps change
en raison des interactions interne alors
objection votre honneur
les organismes qui peuvent acquérir les
nouveaux dispositifs sont davantage
variable en conséquence ils gagnent des
avantages par rapport à d'autres
créatures je veux bien admettre que
c'est une idée qui est très
évolutionniste dans le concept à savoir
que là pour le coup ça semble pointer du
doigt l'idée que le contrôle sur tout le
côté en conséquence ils gagnent des
avantages par rapport à d'autres
créatures
il gagne d'abord des avantages par
rapport à d'autres créatures parce
qu'ils sont variables c'est encore une
fois c'est de l'écologie c'est les
opportunistes donc c'est même pas
tellement de l'évolution encore une fois
c'est sa pointe du doigt le côté où les
opportunistes ont plus de chances
d'avoir des avantages que les créatures
spécialisés après les nouveaux
dispositifs c'est vrai que ça
sous-entend quand même une certaine idée
de dévolution on est bien d'accord mais
on parle surtout là de côté opportuniste
on est presque un peu comme cuvier quand
il dit les partis ne change pas entre
elles sans fin une partie ne peut pas
changer son que sans que les autres
partis change est ce qu'on parle d'eux
est ce qu'on parle d'une comparaison
entre plusieurs espèces ou est ce qu'on
parle vraiment d'évolution
bonne question quoi et alors les décors
changent en raison des interactions
internes et externes interprète la façon
dont j'interprète interactions interne
comme étant de la génétique comme les
sens comme étant une idée précurseur
précurseur de la génétique
je veux dire une interaction interne ça
peut tout aussi bien être ton estomac
avec la bouffe donc là mon petit julia
vous prenez vous essayez un peu de nous
faire passer des vessies pour des
lanternes là mon petit julia de 2014
vous essayez de mon tube est
[Rires]
sérieusement
voilà je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
la façon dont j'interprète et à la
lecture donc de c'est pour ça que
j'étais allée partie le vérifier à la
lecture justement du paragraphe sur tout
si de malick et al là il précise quand
même que madiq dans malik étals pardon
il précise que tout si il est quand même
plus un philosophe qu'un scientifique il
a une façon d'aborder la question de
de la biologie enfin de la zoologie en
l'occurrence plus de façon non plus de
façon scientifique lozeau fiq que
scientifique malassé ici en citant à
alakhbar il al aghbari de 2001
voilà donc ils avaient plutôt tendance à
prendre les comédies il avait plutôt
tendance à prendre les les conclusions
d'abord et puis à y coller ce qui venait
dessus un col et l'effet dessus donc nom
en grosses grosses guillemets la sueur
sur ce passage sera tout si je suis plus
je suis pas du tout du tout d'accord
avec les conneries que je raconte alors
là c'est vraiment la génétique est ce
que est ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il y
avait non vraiment une certaine idée de
la génétique mais qui valent mais non
non pas du tout ah non pas du tout non
cc c'est quand même impressionnant c'est
que ce qu'il a dit donc voilà on va pas
tous voulaient faire les savants loi ce
serait bien ouais ça bien là qu'on
arrête apple massacre et et rend compte
qu'on est qu'à la moitié de la vidéo la
savants musulmans qui ont parlé d'
évolution parce que comme on vous l'a
dit il y en a un paquet et ils sont tous
ont pour la plupart ils sont détaillés
justement dans cet article qui sera dans
la description
d'ailleurs juste pour préciser mais là
donc je reprends un logo google qui qui
qui justement figural tutti à tout si
c'est pas exactement en ligne avec ce
qu'on disait au début sur le fait que ce
qu'ont dit les savants musulmans étaient
peu connus voire inconnus du tout ils
sont très connus ces savants musulmans
ils sont célébrés alors ils sont
essentiellement célébré comme le suggère
très subtilement cette image ils sont et
quand même essentiellement célébrée pour
ce qu'ils ont fait en astronomie et en
mathématiques mais voilà ils sont quand
même connu ces savants musulmans ils
sont pas non plus complètement critique
mais par contre leur contribution à la
biologie à ce moment était pas oublié
mais un peu mis au placard quoi donc
c'est quand même bien de rappeler ce
qu'ils ont fait en biologie et mais
vouloir absolument
là on est à la limite du c'est pas c'est
pas les récits du coran dont mais là on
est à la lie
quand même du concordisme sait on tient
absolument à je tenais absolument à
avoir de l'évolutionnisme tellement
partout que au bout d'un moment voir
juste le mot interaction avec interne
ça voudrait dire de la génétique va
boire un coup julien va boire un grand
verre de lait frais et puis et puis on
va avoir discuté calmement le truc c
voilà quand on quand on lit cet article
on se rend compte qu'il ya un paquet de
musulmans qui parle d'évolution proposé
de près ou de loin ou de très très loin
si on peut aujourd'hui ou au contraire
par l'évolution serait anti religieux
matérialiste du coup qu'est ce qui a
motivé ces savants selon toi qu'est-ce
que et vous reprendrez bien un petit peu
de subtilité
alors la subtilité de l'illustration
galilée devant l'inquisition là je vous
laisse savourer quand même je vous
laisse savourer à quel point cette
illustration est absolument subtil
comparer là c'est le moment où on va
commencer à aborder le contenu du coran
et es6 et cohérent ou pas avec une idée
d'évolution et surtout est-ce que du
coup ce n'est pas cette possibilité cet
espace vide on va dire laissé par le
coran quant à l'origine des espèces
vivantes qui aurait pas favorisé
l'émergence des évolutionnistes parmi
les savants musulmans mais là je vous
laisse juste admirer la subtilité quoi
vous reprendrez bien un petit peu de
subtilité avec votre votre discussion
sur l'effet des religions sur la science
c'est à dire que le dieu solana
il prenait efforts même exigé le
prophète à la réflexion
la réponse est très simple frontières la
civilisation entre tes mains
tu as avec la connaissance d'une part et
la réflexion qu'est musulmans à cette
époque qu'ils avaient leur propre
vivez dans un âge d'or qui l'ont poussé
à vent très très loin leur réflexion
c'est pour ça que c'était cette époque
on a vachement plus de savants musulmans
que maintenant et maintenant alors
pareil relativiser on va relativiser le
à l'âge d'or de la civilisation
musulmane on va dire l'âge d'or ii de
l'ère musulmane ou alors plus tôt il ya
eu beaucoup beaucoup de savants
effectivement est-ce qu'il y en a plus
que maintenant pas forcément il ya
beaucoup de gars quand il ya toujours
beaucoup de scientifiques aujourd'hui
musulmans il ya certainement beaucoup
plus qu'ils en avaient à l'époque par
contre ils ont certes ceux d'aujourd'hui
rayonne pas forcément de la même façon
pour la simple et bonne raison que à
l'époque les savants musulmans étaient
au top niveau
il était au top de leur discipline ils
étaient au top de l'astronomie était au
top des mathématiques à l'époque au top
de la médecine avec avicenne donc voilà
il était au top
à l'époque maintenant les scientifiques
et les grands philosophes et les
littéraires musulmans aujourd'hui
maintenant ils sont quand même je vais
pas dire cryptic mais comparé à leurs
équivalents occidentaux ils sont quand
même largement moins médiatisés ils sont
pas critiques non plus évidemment ils
font des contributions et ses
contributions si vous les cherchez sur
google scholar vous les trouverez mais
comparé à comparer à la façon dont les
contributions des scientifiques
occidentaux sont médiatisés voilà et là
ça vient ça vient d'un chercheur moi qui
travaille en afrique
c'est très difficile de se faire
entendre quand on vient d'afrique quand
on produit de la recherche en afrique
c'est quand même vachement plus
difficile de se faire entendre dans le
monde occidental que quand tu es
directement dans le monde occidental des
cantons universités c'est ça c'est celle
du vide fatal strad quasiment
imprononçable ça vient d'un nom
imprononçable situés en afrique du sud
les gens ils ont un peu tendance à
regarder ça ah bon ça existe ça voilà
donc donc là je m'inscris un peu en faut
quand même il ya tout je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de scientifiques
aujourd'hui qui en a eu j'ai pas vérifié
l'information jeu derrière toute façon
il ya beaucoup plus d'universités
aujourd'hui qui produisent des savants
dans le monde arabo musulman aujourd'hui
qu'il y en a eu à l'époque dû à l'époque
de l'âge d'or de l'islam
par contre là où je suis d'accord c'est
que à l'époque c'était eux le top niveau
il n'avait pas de nous n'avait pas de
concurrent ni de près ni de loin donc là
la culture le savoir venait de ces
savants musulmans ont fait ça il faut
peut-être le dire on est en régression
dans l'est depuis le 15e siècle donc
12h58 et maintenant c'est encore pire
c'est malade je suis pas spécialement
d'accord avec cette affirmation que
j'avais peut-être là encore une fois il
ya les universités top niveau il ya les
universités qui existent en moins qui
sont moins bonnes peut-être que à
l'époque il y avait que des universités
top niveau puisque de toute façon
c'était pas fin à l'époque je parle à
l'époque médiévale les seules
universités qui avait été forcément top
niveau
en tout cas les seuls dont on se
rappelle aussi son top niveau c'est
toujours pareil à le biais le fameux
billet du c'était mieux avant le biais
de nostalgie tout était mieux avant
évidemment les seules choses dont on se
rappelle ce sont des choses qui ont
laissé leur marque dans l'histoire on va
pas se rappeler de toutes les petites
universités ou de tous les petits salons
et aujourd'hui voilà donc il faut pas
non plus faut comparer ce qui est
comparable c'est là où je veux en venir
c'est qu'il faudrait et là en
l'occurrence je pense pas qu'on soit en
train de comparer des comparables
aimerait dire aussi que le premier
verset où se rate coranique
prenez à la réflexion de la république
en latéral
il ya 36 ans quelle que soit l'issue
l'exigence à la réflexion c'est pas
juste sur le logement entre lire ou par
nécessité il faut il faut le faire ce
qu'on appelle en arabe mais
malheureusement parfois quand je lis
certains traduction on sent pas que on
ressent pas que c'est vraiment important
c'est c'est pas lire ou il faut
réfléchir mais c'est plus que quelqu'un
sait c'est juste un petit détail
cancon conscient alors que que si dieu a
envoyé
c'est ce premier set première sourate
qui prenait le prophète à la réflexion
ce n'est pas pour rien donc voilà on
essaye en gros de justifier pourquoi
pourquoi les savants musulmans de
l'époque se sont permis de parler
d'évolution et notamment jusqu'à libéral
donne d'une origine simiesque de l'homme
à l'opposé de ce qu'il a écrit dans le
récit de la genèse savoir que l'être
humain était fabriquée par dieu dans la
glaise
comment ils se sont permis en fait dans
les jeux aussi loin et donc l'idée ce
serait que le coran en fête invite à la
réflexion il ya une vraiment un passage
un verset du coran qui dit fin dans la
sourate pour le coup aussi là si j'ai
bien suivi là une sourate du coran qui
dit il faut que tu réfléchissent à la
création de dieu qui en gros ils
s'étaient ils étaient ils étaient
vraiment il était à mon avis c'était
vraiment des prêtres étaient frères
musulmans il est né ce qu'ils disent
qu'il faisait et il était en parfaite
conscience est convaincue par les
versets coraniques et que c'est grâce à
cet important de préciser il y en a qui
y en ait un qui sont allez me dire que
j'aurais laissé savoir musulmans dont on
parle depuis tout à l'heure était a été
hâtée était laïque non non comme je les
dis ah le concept de création divine il
est toujours présent dans leur décrire
tout le temps donc c'était des vrais
musulmans
c'était pas des laïcs du tout c'est que
le corps il incite à la réflexion à
l'islam recommande la recherche de la
science lusage de l'intelligence et de
la raison je cite on peut te livre de
georges salines qui parle de ça donc
l'islam où elle recommanderait la
recherche de la science c'est l'art
c'est non seulement le courant mais
aussi dans l'ensemble donc lens nantes
c'est ce qui a été dit par le groupe est
donc le professeur par exemple il a
beaucoup beaucoup prenaient à votre
question il faut aller chercher la
science même si elle est en chine
donc moi je trouve que c'est inversé
extra extra ordinaire donc c'est juste
c'est de retrouver
c'est juste pour pour pour te dire à
quel point les gens de 2,7 points il
était passionné et même on se fait si on
voit les il faut aller chercher la
science jusqu'en chine ça me fait penser
à ibn battouta qui était un des premiers
explorateurs un des premiers grands
explorateurs musulmans en tout cas de
l'explorateur musulman le plus connu qui
a vraiment pour le coup traversez la
totalité quasi totalité du monde
musulman des stands reste jusqu'en chine
notamment
donc c'était quand même
ouais il ya quand même des gens qui
prenaient ça au pied de la lettre a pour
le coup en fait dans par exemple la
civilisation la dernière civilisation
musulmane donc c'était c'était c'était
la bassine abbassides dans ce qui est
décrit par le rock de tous les temps
avec toutes les étapes les étapes de la
création de la dernière civilisation je
pense qu'il veut dire dernière dynastie
mais du coup la dernière dynastie et
musulmane c'est les ottomans c'est pas
les abbassides c'est bizarre comme comme
affirmation plus haut dans la société
il était respecté par tout le monde et
le respect du simple société c'était
quand même c'était obligatoire
il y avait des
des universités avec des cours qui
étaient donnés au public gratuitement
ces jeunes exacte n'était pas tout à
fait des universités mais ce que l'on
dit la section c'était des places de
culture c'est ce qu'on appelle l modéles
c'était dans les dents avec mosquées
notamment tout était enseigné non sans
blessure par la religion donc la
religion et sur la religion
les descriptions et coraniques ou cela
et il ya aussi dans le coran il
enseignait ils ont signé divers sciences
mathématiques à ce qu'on me et médecine
etc etc que c'était c'était le sg de la
dame inscrits s'étaient pas juste juste
un lieu de prière mais c'était aussi un
lieu pour pour enseigner pour pour faire
les débats pour débattre si tu as une
idée du tu peux tu peux tu peux la
débattre devant les gens et est alors
puisqu'on parle du coran est ce que dans
le corps il est vraiment fait mention
aussi clairement que dans la genèse
biblique de la création bien est ce que
est ce que la porte laissée ouverte à la
possibilité d'une évolution des espèces
en fait dans le coran demanda-t-il très
subtilement c'est très très ouvert et
c'est un sujet juste pas si ouvert que
ça non là on a un peu on a un peu
exagéré quand même l'ouverture il ya
deux façons on va en parler mais je veux
dire le il y à là même le même passage
de la genèse où il est dit que dieu
allah a créé l'homme à partir de la
glaise
donc c'est pas si ouvert que ça non plus
par contre il ya un truc en plus on va
en parler juste après qui laisse quand
même la porte ouverte à une certaine
idée de l'évolution encore des voitures
jusqu'à maintenant
donc c'est pas comme la jeunesse public
où c'était clair et net
donc voilà il y avait ma gêne a su y
avait la création de l'homme et par un
stade encore deux semaines dans une
semaine mais bas mais non dans le coron
peut-être on pas percevoir une certaine
jeunesse du public
mais parallèlement il y avait aussi une
certaine certains idée d'interdire
certaines digues et évolutif
comme par exemple la création des
espèces énarque création et la
régénération de deux êtres alliera donc
la région
la régénération de la création peut-être
que ça sous-entend que il y avait dix
teintes de transformation ça sous-entend
que ya probablement des phases
d'extinction et probablement des
radiations après donc voilà donc c'est
juste pour te dire que c'est très très
ouvert c'est pas vraiment fixé comme
comme la bible la langue je suis pas en
train de critiquer la vue bien sûr mais
c'est c'est vraiment très floue armes
ah ouais finalement sur
certaines traductions du corps on a par
exemple à la et celui qui crée l'espèce
qu'il a recréé cet accord de lui que
vous reviendrez et une autre une autre
traduction de ce même verset c'est dieu
commence la création ensuite la répète
donc effectivement alors il ya beaucoup
là on fait vraiment une analyse neutre
est anachronique en parlant d'extinction
et de radiation évolutive après ça
évidemment déjà ça c'est le premier
point on a une analyse très très
anachronique de ces versets du coran
mais si on se remet dans le contexte on
a quand même cette idée que à la craie
et recrée que l'évolution enfin que la
création et répétée ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait la crise il faut bien c'est
surtout le fait que ce soit dix au
présent je pense qu'il est important
c'est à dire que c'est pas juste dieu a
créé par le passé et c'est tout ça c'est
la bible ainsi la genèse
c'est dieu est le créateur et il crée et
il crée en continu voilà il ya cette
idée en fait de création continue qui je
pense est là je suis toujours d'accord à
peu près avec ce qu'on dit là pour le
coup au delà de l'analyse d'anachronique
du verset du verset coranique mais il y
a quand même cette idée que la
possibilité d'une création en continu
n'est pas exclue ce qui de fait n'exclut
pas la possibilité que les espèces
changent au fil du temps et le
changement des espèces ou de fuite du
temps c'est l'évolution l'évolution ça
n'est jamais que du changement d'espèces
au fil du temps donc l'idée de
changement d'espèces au fil du temps
n'est pas exclut complètement à priori
par le par le corps et s'accoupler avec
le fait que le corps enfin les sourates
appel à la culture appelle à étudier le
monde pour comprendre la création du
créateur ça veut dire face à tout ça mis
ensemble est susceptible d'avoir créé on
va dire un petit bouillon par lequel
paducah elle a pu émerger justement
cette idée on va dire de de porosité
dans la scala natura et qu'on a souligné
plus tôt donc là encore une fois on est
on explique ça très très très
maladroitement très de façon très très
très anachronique mais je pense que
l'idée de fond et de là en fait c'est
que contrairement à une lecture
littérale de la bible ou la possibilité
que d'une évolution est complètement
exclu la possibilité de changement même
sur une lecture très littérale du coran
et des sourates elle n'est pas non plus
totalement exclue
voilà ce que je pense c'est surtout là
où on veut en venir presque une
sensation alors de legrand c'est un
texte qui a été écrit au 6e siècle
si je ne me trompe pas on n'a déjà plus
ou moins une forme de catastrophisme à
la cuvier au [ __ ] faut pas entendre
non là ça fait une heure et demi que ça
dure en fin de la vidéo fait qu'une demi
heure à la base mais là ça fait une
heure et demi que je parle
honnêtement ça fait mal d'entendre
encore ça sur la fin de la vidéo du
cuvier rythme du cuvier risme dans le
corps voyons donc encore une fois
analyse hyper anachronique
les créations et les re création web
comprend d'où j'ai tiré cette idée là
l'idée qu'il y avait des recréations
c'est effectivement lorsque cuvier va
défendre
mille ans plus tard dans son
catastrophisme mais enfin de là à y voir
une porosité encore de là il voit une
connexion une porosité entre les deux
faut pas déconner c'est une coïncidence
le dire l'idée d'une création et d'une
recréation elle émerge assez
naturellement du registre fossile pour
quelqu'un qui veut pas croire à
l'évolution comme cuvier et l'idée d'une
création et d'une recréation pour à
l'époque le coran a été écrit je sais
pas exactement d'où elle a pu sortir
mais elle voulait certainement pas dire
la même chose
plus de 900 ans plus tard c'est ça
ressemble pas mal il ya déjà un
progressisme dans les idées qui était
formidable et surtout donc une ouverture
d'esprit qui est non seulement
recommandée mais comme tu oublies et qui
est même plus que recommandée
effectivement il y avait il y avait
beaucoup de corps ont en fait il était
toujours derrière l'ouverture des
esprits donc eh ben il va être un peu
temps de conclure donc qu'est-ce qu'on
peut tirer de tout ça bien que
finalement la pensée évolutionniste a
précédé de très loin la naissance de
darwin l'évolution ou du mois la non
fixité de ça j'aime bien ça j'aime bien
je pense qu'on devrait le réutiliser
plus souvent ça darwin c'est ni le seul
ni le premier et surtout pas le dernier
voilà tout ce qui nous cite des passages
de darwin pour nous dire b darwin il a
dit que ça donc ça veut dire que
l'évolution un faust et puis tant darwin
c'est ni le seul ni le premier et
surtout pas le dernier
ça c'est clair que ça c'est une plaie
des espèces existait déjà dès le 5ème
siècle donc on en a parlé tout à l'heure
de haru 10 à mardi à taiz il y avait
aussi un petit peu
alors en plus occidental il y avait
saint-augustin un peu qu'ils étaient
déjà non fixiste bien que à
saint-augustin mans fixiste sérieusement
ou est-ce que j'ai tiré sa couenne
saint-augustin non fixiste genre menée
au ivème siècle après jésus-christ quoi
tu vas me dire que saint-augustin et et
non fixiste je ne sais pas peut-être
qu'après je dis tout j'ai tiré cette
info mais ça me semble un peu gros
on était sûrs d'eux plutôt sur la
dégénérescence des espèces que
réellement sur de l'évolution des
espèces
oui ça c'est un truc qu'il faut bien
ouais ça ça ça c'est important ça parce
que l'idée de dégénérescence elle est
omniprésente à l'époque médiévale déjà à
l'antiquité et ensuite à l'époque
médiévale c'est à dire que oui belle
notamment chez les chrétiens c'était
l'idée que les êtres humains sont
devenus de plus en plus petit c'est à
dire que les premiers êtres humains
étaient des géants et qu'ensuite ils ont
ratissé et que leur longévité aussi à
des diminué ça c'était pour rationaliser
le fait que dans la bible les premiers
les premiers personnages bibliques ont
des durées de vie de plusieurs centaines
d'années apparemment alors que les êtres
humains aujourd'hui ils vivent que
quelques dizaines d'années
donc ils essayaient de rationaliser tout
ça en disant ah ben voilà les humains
étaient vachement plus grand et du coup
ils vivent est vachement plus longtemps
donc il ya une idée de dégénérescence
qui est toujours présente à peu près
tout le temps dans le dans la culture au
moins chrétienne et je pense qu'elle est
aussi présente dans la culture musulmane
et cette idée de dégénérescence
d'ailleurs on la retrouve
on la retrouve chez ald jaillissent si
ma mémoire est bonne
alger 10 qui dit qui nous dit qu'il nous
dit il y a des nabatéens dont des
navigateurs nabatéens qui ressemblent à
des singes dans certaines régions
géographiques
il est possible que l'air pollué et
l'eau ainsi que la poussière ont mené à
ces changements de caractère chez les
marocains donc
déjà bon algérie ce qui du coup était
était natif de ce qui aujourd'hui l'irak
retrouve que les marocains sont des
êtres dégénéré vont évidemment comme je
le disais le barbare c'est toujours le
barbare c'est toujours l'autre mais là
déjà bon le gros racisme toujours bien
bien saupoudré toujours comme il faut et
mais bon ça encore une fois c'est une
analyse anachronique d'un texte qui date
de 2 600 et des infos pas non plus
déconner mais c'est surtout le côté ou
voilà on a cette idée aussi de
dégénérescence là qui fait ressembler
plus à des sages dans ce cas là que des
cadets ya des humains donc à l' masque
donc une sorte de sage
voilà donc donc cette idée de
dégénérescence à la toujours plus ou
moins flotter dans l'air aussi mais
c'est vraiment une idée est ce que c'est
une idée qu'on peut réellement associé
au transformisme je ne sais pas c'est
cette idée en fait de dégénérescence ça
ne fait pas forcément changé les espèces
c'est à dire que les humains géant de
l'antiquité c'était des humains toujours
c'était s'est toujours considéré
essentiellement et là le mot
essentiellement des très important c'est
toujours considéré comme essentiellement
des humains leur récent c'est toujours
humaine c'est juste que c'est des
humains différents et c'est pas
d'ailleurs particulièrement une
adaptation à quoi que ce soit c'est
juste de vraiment de la dégénérescence
oncle à cette idée de dégénérescence
était assez omniprésente à l'époque
médiévale mais on peut pas vraiment dire
que c'était un pas en avant vers un
transformisme dans le sens du cep ça ne
changeait pas les espèces qu'on est
d'ailleurs ça s'opposent généralement à
l'idée du fait que dans la théorie de
l'évolution
je dirais pas qu'il ya une sorte de
progrès c'est pas vrai il n'ya pas une
sorte de progrès mais il ya quand même
l'idée que la génération suivante est
mieux adapté à son environnement que la
génération précédente
ou alors elle s'éteint voilà donc il ya
tout il ya quand même une idée de de
s'améliorer par rapport à un contexte
environnemental et génétique et
écologique etc etc
mais il ya quand même l'idée que la
génération suivante est quand même mieux
adaptées entre guillemets
que la génération précédente donc là
c'est complètement opposées en fait à
l'idée de dégénérescence c'est l'idée
était la même à voir darwin avant la
publication de l'origine des espèces
il y avait eu robert chambers en 1844
qui parlait déjà d'évolution des espèces
dans vestiges de l'histoire naturelle de
la création donc en réalité bien
l'évolution elle était dans l'air est ce
que darwin il a apporté
c'est une pierre ce peut être la plus
grosse pierre de l'édifice
évolutionnisme mais ce n'est qu'une
pierre et cette bière c'est la sélection
naturelle c'est-à-dire qu'on avait un
patron l'évolution mais on ne savait pas
l'expliquer jusque-là et darwin nous a
dit bah voilà comment ça marche ça
marche par sélection naturelle
et justement ça marrant dit et al jalil
avait déjà formulé des idées dans le
même sens milan avant lui
donc non non il n'avait pas savait pas
cette idée de sélection naturelle
c'est largement là on est vraiment en
train de largement exagéré de grossir un
trait qui est très très faim dans les
oeuvres de samarkand i et ii à jane
qu'une forme de proto sélection
naturelle si je peux dire de pré
sélection naturelle avant l'heure mais
mais qui ne marche pas parce que juste
définir la loi du plus fort sans parler
ensuite de la descendance avec
modification ça fait pas une théorie de
l'évolution
voilà tout ça tout ça était dans l'air
bien avant darwin même son grand père
déjà parler d'émergence des voiles
erasmus darwin par les mêmes déjà
d'évolution des espèces donc il y avait
il y avait un background qu'on oublie
toujours quand on fait quand on fait ce
culte à darwin quasiment parce que là il
ya des moments on a bien vu par exemple
sont les le bicentenaire de l'évolution
il y avait tout un culte autour de
darwin mais darwin ce n'est pas le seul
loin de là
ni le seul ni le premier et ça n'a pas
été le dernier heureusement c'est pas le
bicentenaire de la théorie de
l'évolution c'est le bicentenaire de la
naissance de darwin qu'on a fêté en 2009
ben il faut arrêter de dire de la merde
un mot de la fin un mot de la fin sera
pantin
le sujet c'est sur l'évolution moi je
trouve quand même que c'est
indispensable tout dans le signer
l'évolution à nos enfants dans des
écoles dans des collèges je pense que
c'est indispensable si tu vas pas ça
c'est peut-être j'adresse ce petit mot
notamment nos frères musulmans madame si
tu vas pas connaître et décrypter
l'évolution c'est que tu peux rien faire
par la suite
tu peux pas comprendre les mécanismes
biologiques tu peux pas comprendre la
biologie conscience de large
tu peux pas comprendre la géologie et
bien évidemment si on a envie de tacler
dans huit attaques est acquise par
exemple où les habituels
il suffit d'abord de les lire il faut il
faut dire d'abord si savants fortin pis
les critiques pour avoir un avis
critique il faut il faut d'abord savoir
de combien exactement
des paroles prophétiques mon choix un
avis critique vaut mieux savoir de quoi
on parle non j'ajouterai à ce que dit
abdou que voilà si tu veux pas le savoir
juste pour ta propre connaissances
biologiques connaître la théorie de
l'évolution c'est quand même avoir une
meilleure idée de où on vient et avoir
une meilleure idée de où on via ça évite
d'avoir quelqu'un d'autre qui vous
racontent de vous aimer et notamment qui
vous racontent que lui vient d'un
meilleur endroit que vous voilà si quand
on sait que tous les êtres humains on le
met dans cette rencontre m'a
immédiatement l'idée que l'idée d'une
race supérieure qui conviendraient les
autres s'évapore elle s'évapore tout
comme ça et ça s'appelait pas évidemment
à tous les suprémacistes quelle que soit
leur couleur de peau et ça ne plaît pas
évidemment à tous ceux qui essaieraient
de gouverner les autres sous prétexte
qu'il leur serait supérieur
donc voilà si vous voulez pas être chez
eux si vous voulez pas être gouvernés
par quelqu'un qui se considère comme
supérieur que vous eh bien sachez
connaissez l'histoire de vos origines et
vous ne vous ferez pas raconter des
histoires de votre origine par d'autres
gens merci beaucoup à vous merci à toi
merci à toi j'espère que la prochaine
fois
d'autres vidéos relatives à ce sujet qui
me tient vraiment à coeur
hélas au plaisir vous et le vieux logo
de notre chaîne
et ça se termine sont de vieux logo de
notre chaîne cette vidéo a déjà été bien
assez longue
ça fait mal de voir des vieux trucs utah
ça ça a déjà six ans rendez compte a
déjà six ans que le temps passe vite
sept ans bientôt c'est en 13 mars mais
oui peut-être que au moment où vous
regardez cette vidéo sont peut-être même
déjà septembre
et bien je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
ce débat kg pénitence la pénitence fut
lourde la pénitence plus longue mais je
crois que ce fcn c'est une des
pénitences pour laquelle je finis en
meilleur état
finalement j'avais pas dit tant de
conneries que ça mais ça méritait quand
même de dire passer du temps ça méritait
quand même deux rangs de de mettre des
petits sparadraps sur beaucoup de choses
qui étaient fausses
parfois même des grosses parades parfois
même c'était des trous béants en réalité
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo et je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne salut